but also at the highest darwinian level
that we got to make it
as a as an as a civilization you can
think about it as one
cellular organism that really wants to
divide
to undergo mitosis the whole planet but
that our little cell cycle our cell
checkpoint
that we have to get to that checkpoint
in order to divide and to go into the
recursion
but in order to get there all of the
little organelles
inside of the cell all the different
nations and all the different molecules
like us
individuals need to have a high level of
intracellular communication
in order to be able to get to that cell
checkpoint and to undergo mitosis and to
go through the recursive process
into the next flavors in the infinite
candy store that we're exploring
so maybe that consciousness is exploring
infinity
and it's a big unbounded map and we're
forever doing that
and that your metaphysics of quality
your values your determining of what is
good with your free will
determines how successful we are
at achieving both our individual goals
and our collective destiny
so every single decision you make has to
do
with the telos of the cosmos
that's a big thing that's a big thing